hello you took just lovers in our
friends this is grunge in here now if
you don't know how to play against the
Scandinavian defense or you might having
some problems from surface model
variations then you came at the right
place because in today's video I'm going
to show you how to get an advantageous
position against most of the
Scandinavian defense lines now the line
which I'm going to recommend in this
video are played adopted and favourite
by some of the world's top grandmasters
and the good thing from the white
perspective is against all the
Scandinavian defense mowers our plan of
campaign are pretty much similar so join
with me and learn how to defuse the
Scandinavian defense now after white
plays d4 Scandinavian defense more start
with the mu d file and here I recommend
you should certainly capture this pawn
and here you can see I have highlighted
by the arrows black has a few options
but among those are the only two options
which are good our Knight to f6 and
Queen crossed e-file but before going
into the main moves let's deal some of
the gambit ideas by black so first move
is black and try this tricky gambit
which is e 6 well against this white has
a very fantastic reply which is Bishop
to b5 check and now you can see black
has a two good options over here
black lacy six then the very simple will
be D cross six and after let's say pawn
captures all the knight captures let's
say in one of my game my opponent
capture with the knight but after I
played Knight to f3 you can see not only
white is a clear pawn up but white is
not also lagging behind me development
in the next move white will castle on
the King side and in the whole game
white will remain upon up so I don't
understand what logic behind giving up
the pawn like this so that is c6 now the
most logical reply looks like Bishop to
d7 but here there is a nasty trap exist
for the wire so please watch out for
this one and here white has a cunning
move which is d cross e6 if the F cross
E six then the black pawn structure will
be ragged so the most logical reply
looks like Bishop cross bishop but
afterwards White has a very simple reply
which is e cross f7 and after King cross
f7 White has this lethal check which
will regain the piece and please note at
this position white will be a clear two
points up as well as black has lost the
castle right that is about ecigs
now here black can also try the another
gambit idea which is the c6 here why -
certainly capture this pawn and after
Knight to c6 my simple recommendation is
you just carry out your normal piece
development so for example you can play
knight two or three against one of my
game my upon responded with Bishop to a5
afterwards I play Bishop to c4 and after
ecigs I played Knight to c3 and some of
the moves are like this so he played
Knight to f6
I played castle on the King side after
Bishop to c5 I simply play d3 and after
he castle on the King side
I played Bishop therefore what's going
on nothing special
both side are pretty much equal the only
drawback black is having his he is a
clear pawn down and if you play
accurately from here onwards you can
easily convert this sort of games into
the winning game so that is about ecigs
and c6 let's start with some of the main
moves of the scandium defense and the
first move I want to consider is Knight
to f6
which is known as modern Scandinavian
defense here there are a few tricks and
traps exist exist which you need to
watch out
you meet this position first time then
you are likely to play this move which
is c4
it looks very logical because it's
protecting the pawn and what's wrong
with this but the idea is now black can
launch a vicious gambits and that can be
proved very very dangerous for example
black and try a six which is known as
Icelandic gambit and now if I capture
this pawn black will certainly recapture
with the bishop and I certainly believe
that black has enough compensation for
one pawn because it has a tremendous
piece development and there are some
nasty theories exist for this lines so
all together I'm suggesting you that you
completely avoid this also there is a
second gambit idea which is the c6 and
here also if you capture this pawn black
will capture with the night and again
black has a tremendous piece development
so please avoid all this nonsense also
if you play here the simple looking move
d4 then black can try another tricky
move which is Bishop to g4 and this is
known as jar dual gambit and there is a
long theory exist or for this line so
rather facing those sorts of variations
where black knows their stuff very well
and what is fighting for the initiative
what I recommend here is you follow the
simple step which I am going to
recommend in this video with start with
the move Bishop to e2 now Bishop to e2
has a simple idea first of all it's
stopping Bishop to g4
and after night cross defy you stop that
night coming to the f4 by playing D for
you and let me reveal the wide structure
at this point so what white is aiming
for in the most of the scenario is white
will play Knight to f3 followed by
castle on the Kings side and then drive
this night with the move c4 let's say
this night go to the b6 and now this
Bishop can go to either III f4 or GI
depending on the circumstances the most
active square for this Bishop is f4 and
afterwards this Knight has a to
wonderful squares now if the position is
free then I certainly recommend that you
play Knight to c3 and afterwards you can
see the plan of campaign from the white
is very very simple so white has the two
plants now so first plan I have
highlighted by the arrows over here
white can look forward for the a 3 and B
4 move and gain space on the Queen side
and the other plan which is very
effective in the most of the scenario is
you play Queen to d2 these two rooks can
be aggressively placed either on c1 d1
or even and then white can look forward
for the central breaks these are two
very very effective plants by the white
and please note white has a tremendous
space advantage because of this c4 and
d4 most so this is the pretty much plan
of the white if black does not do
anything and sig passively now what I'm
going to do in this lecture is
going to show you the lines where white
is having problem to carry out this
plans in the rest of the scenario you
should certainly follow the plant which
I have recommended the first system
which is designed to confuse the white
line is start with this move which is g6
so now the idea is very simple black
wants to play Bishop to g7 and castle on
the Queen side here I recommend that
instead of normal Knight to f3 you
immediately kick that night and after
Knight go to the b6 now you play Knight
to c3 the simple reason is when black
plays Bishop to g7 which has a merit of
attacking that pawn why it has a
wonderful forcing lines with start with
the move c5 Knight to d7 is a bit
passive so most likely most of the time
the opponent is going to play Knight to
d5 and hear you play Bishop to c4 and
now you can see two PCs are attacking
the knight and if you oppor and place a
six then that will locked up that Bishop
and if you open and play c6 then that
will take the wonderful square from this
Knight so that's why black has to
forcefully capture this Knight
now before we look at night cross c3
let's see what will happen if your
opponent tries either of this move so in
one of my game my opponent plays c6 and
I responded with Knight to f3 and here
he pinned us not with Bishop to g4 I
played a very cunning move which is
Queen to b3 and Queen to b3 is attacking
to sports o b7 as well as the light so
my opponent first of all capture this
night and after I recaptured he played
Bishop cross d4 which is a kind of
mistake because then I simply capture
that night and after black recapture I
simply capture that pawn with my bishop
and now you can see this - Queen and
Bishop battery is not only attacking the
AB 7 but it's also attacking the b7 and
black cannot defend both the threat so
in the game my opponent played castle on
the King side but afterwards I simply
capture the b7 with the Queen my
opponent responded with Knight to d7
afterwards I simply kept that rook and
after Queen captures Bishop recaptures
rook captures I simply played Bishop to
e3 as far as I can see why it is a clear
exchange of and in the game I easily
managed to win so that game will give
you an idea what kind of disaster can
Lou if black plays c6 the best option
here for the black will be to capture
this Knight but afterwards White will
recapture with the b-pawn and now you
can see by capturing this way we have
blunt the diagonals of this Bishop so
most of the time your opponent is going
to castle on the King side and now you
carried out your normal pace development
so you play Knight to f3 and if your
opponent place Bishop to g4 then I
recommend you just nab the bishop pair
by playing h3 and after Bishop captures
Queen captures this is the case of one
of my game and hear my opponent
responded with c6
and I simply played Rupe to be one so
once again renewing the threat of
capturing that pong and good thing is
Queen cannot come to c7 because it can
be attack one more time with Bishop to
f4 so in the game my opponent responded
with Queen to see it afterwards I simply
castle on the King side and you can see
white position is already very good and
black pieces are very very passive let's
see how to be in progress so my opponent
plays Knight to d7 afterwards I played
route to even so attacking the a pawn
and hear my opponent responded with
Bishop to f6 which is a kind of small
mistake that allows me to play Bishop 2
at 6 attacking the rook and after rook
to e8 I simply played h4 and you can see
the plan of campaign from the White is
very very easy all I want to play is H
Phi weaken the black King and then go
for the attack hear my opponent knows
that H Phi is coming and somehow he was
frustrated about his position so he
played this hilarious move which is e
file this is outright mistake because
now I simply capture that point
generally you won't capture this sort of
things because that will give you an
isolated C CC pause but this is a
completely favorable position that's why
we capture that pawn and hear my
opponent capture with the roof which
will simplify more because I capture
that rook and after Bishop captures I
simply give this check and my opponent
played King to h8 that's the only move
left afterward pressurize more
rook to e1 and now you can see my simple
plan is to capture this Knight and then
give a checkmate to the black king so my
opponent decided to defend with Bishop
to f6 Bishop to f6 not only protect the
critical g7 but is also preventing the
route coming to the e7 but when you are
defending you only defend you never get
time to attack and this is exactly
happen in this game so I simply played
another good move which is route to b6
and now that Bishop has to move and in
the game my opponent capture the C pole
and that allows me to finish the game
very very quickly so I played rook to e7
and now you can see not only at 7s
attack but d7 is also attack and black
cannot protect both the things so my
opponent resigned over here so that is
how you need to respond when your
opponent plays moves such as g6
now there is under plan by the black
which has been recommended by Andrew
Martin in his video about the modern
Scandinavian and who recommended that
blacks should play Bishop to f5 and the
recommended plan by him was something
like this so black wants to play a six
followed by the Bishop to e7 then castle
on the Kings side and then quickly go
for the move C file so this is the
pretty much recommended plan by the
Andrew well against this what I
recommend is after Bishop to fi you play
Knight to f3 and after black plays a six
you play castle on the King side and
after Bishop to e7 you play a slightly
cunning move which is a three after
black castle on the King side now you
play c4 so you can see the first merit
of the a3 is this Knight cannot go to
the b4 so that means this Knight has to
go to the b6 and afterwards you just
carry out your normal piece development
with Knight to c3 now as per the plan
recommended if black plays see fine now
then the very simple will be you are
going to capture that one and which
attacks tonight now here in this version
whether the Queen exchange or not but
the resulting position is very very
favorable to the white so for example in
one of my game
my opponent capture this pawn with the
bishop and that allowed me to gain space
on the Queen side with the move before
and now after Bishop to e7
I simply avoid the kleenex chain with
Queen to b3 and after Knight to c6
I played rook to d1 and that has a mat
of attacking the Queen so my opponent
plays Queen to c7 afterwards I simply
played c5 attacking the knight and now
the Knight has to passively retrieve to
the d7
afterwards carry on with my initiative
with night to b5 once again attacking
the Queen and after Queen to c8 I simply
played Knight to d6 look at that night
it's so wonderfully placed and black has
no option to remove that night so when
the game I opponent capture that night
afterwards I played see cross d6 and now
that pawn is a big big puzzle
if white can manage to hold on to that
pole then White has a very comfortable
game so let's see how the game
progressed so in the game my opponent
plays rook to d8 afterwards I played
Bishop to b2 and hear my opponent plays
Knight to b6
so now it's somehow trying to attack
that D pawn I just simply play it look
to c1 so now I have a concrete threat of
flame b5 which my opponent avoided with
a 6
afterwards I play Knight to h4 so which
has a merit of attacking the bishop and
if somehow I can get the bishop pair
then what is doing quite fine so in the
game my opponent plays Bishop to e4 that
allow me to finish the game immediately
can you spot the move yep is Queen to e3
which has a merit of attacking to piece
and black cannot defend both the threat
these are the only two sidelines you
need to aware amongst the rest the plan
which I have recommended in the starting
of the video you can comfortably follow
the plan and I'll give you guarantee you
get a very comfortable and advantageous
position as a white